where we are or over 50 that's
unbelievable
hmm did you tell like we've barely
talked I know we barely talked I feel
like I don't really didn't really ask
him all that much
dude I'll stay here you have beat
Ethan's way well no first of all let's
just get this out of the way for did the
guy respond to you hold on which I got
to finish some more [ __ ] at home but
down to see it soon I really want to
sign
Quinn Tarantino who is this guy it was a
group of friends and they all kind of
said the same thing I just used one
person's to say that so all your friends
said no yeah everyone said no it's Dylan
again Wow okay I don't understand I
don't understand how people can not
scream like I feel I don't know how to
do that I just do it here's the thing
though it's that here's why the movie
I'm not gonna give away anything but the
reason why the movie is [ __ ] up is
because they show things in the movie
that you generally shouldn't show that's
right right well you go a director would
gum I think that's too much yeah you can
just allude to it oh you're gonna lewd
to it but they got away now I'm not just
give it away but they do it in a most
because the frames is some of these
images are so beautifully lit mm-hm and
framed that they could be they could
have been paintings oh wow but what
you're seeing is something that's very
like disturbing mm-hmm and let me see
this right just kind of like The Shining
cuz that that's really exactly what was
happening in that like that scene with
the with the girl in the bathtub yeah
that's a good point yeah yeah that's a
very good point
and then um there are also random things
like at the time I think the two twins
being in the hallway was just up my god
yeah yeah it was just a random like what
the [ __ ] when you're a kid watching that
movie The Shining that's all you think
about is all you think about like when
you're walking out
hallway you're like I don't want to see
two children now not only that the way
you write happiest things in the world
you I don't wanna see too right they're
obviously the obviously they're like
malnutrition right and they're wearing
something that you don't like blue
dresses yeah but like also it's framed
in a way where it could be drawn yeah as
a painting it's another you know I'm
just saying this guy re austere isn't it
I think this is the first movie Wow and
I and Dylan I'm afraid that you're not
gonna watch it if you don't watch it
tonight I'm gonna oh I'm gonna watch
that you're gonna watch tonight I'm
gonna watch it you gonna go you want to
go yeah afterwards oh sure yeah I'm down
because I felt like I felt like because
your friends oh no no I don't work out
let's go we could have a separation
obscene oh you want to go I can't dude
why Cindy I'm just saying that you know
my friends saying no to wasn't that
weird yeah yeah you guys are out let's
do it you'll go you'll go oh my brother
has said that yeah oh really is that
what he said that's amazing but
undermine it but here's the thing under
Mike I tweeted it and some comments were
like nah I guess it depends on what on
your like history and what scares you
like any type of like weird I mean I
said that that Westworld sucked last
night I don't know if you guys watched
Westworld I do yeah okay I because it
was one linear so when I said that some
people were like I don't what are you
talking about didn't suck and the reason
they didn't think it sucks is because it
was one linear storyline but they added
a character in but then took the
character away because it was like Oh
was the girl talking idea but anyways
that was a spoiler for that but someone
else they were like well finally I
didn't have to think about the other
storylines oh [ __ ] you man at a point of
the [ __ ] show
whoa you saw all of the West worlds yeah
do you like Game of Thrones I haven't
seen any of it oh yeah I'm waiting for
like a long hall tour when I'm on the
road for like a month and I'm gonna
watch every I feel like that's the
proper way to honor because I'm already
so far away yeah and I got a because I
know that when I watch it I'm gonna
watch it like I'm gonna I'm gonna have
[ __ ] up nights where I will stay up
until like 7:00 a.m. guys I didn't sleep
yeah yeah I should watch it soon or
before the final season maybe that way
you can share an hour but I really I
also just kind of want to watch it way
later so that I start tweeting about the
first season and people like stupid yeah
that's funny do that yeah yeah yeah did
the first season guys Game of Thrones is
so crazy
holy [ __ ] Persis ran was pushed be a
[ __ ] up ten years later live tweeting
yeah yeah that's so funny yeah
[Music]